leaders have a much less active or
controlling role than we sometimes want
to thank the best they can do is produce
something between the followers that
enables us to do it hey and welcome to
the sunday special we have on as our
guest today a very special guest General
Stanley McChrystal author of the new
book leaders myth in reality I want to
get to all of that but first let's talk
about your upcoming death I mean
hopefully it's not that soon hopefully
you have many years to go but whenever
you plotz you're going to think well I
should have had life in time you may not
be thinking anything but you would have
been thinking on your deathbed that
perhaps you would have needed life
insurance it's not a fun topic to think
about you don't like thinking about your
death you don't like thinking about life
insurance but actually having life
insurance it's great getting that peace
of mind doesn't need to be complicated
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford from there you can apply online
the unbiased advisors and policy genius
will handle all the red tape leaving you
free to do all the things you actually
enjoy doing and policy genius doesn't
just make life insurance easy whether
you're shopping for disability insurance
to protect your income or homeowners
insurance or auto insurance that can
help you get covered fast so if you've
been intimidated or frustrated by
insurance in the past give policy genius
a try just go to policy genius com get
your quotes apply in minutes you can do
the whole thing on your phone right this
very instant policy genius is indeed the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance when you plot you want to make
sure that your family doesn't have to
bury you in a pauper's grave they'll
make sure you're paid for it go check it
out policy genius the easy way to buy
life insurance well general McChrystal
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it thanks for having me and
call me Stan okay sounds good so Stan
and it feels disrespectful even though
you just told me I could Stan let me
start by asking you about sort of your
life story for folks who don't know your
your back story where did you come from
obviously folks know you for your for
your leadership in the military and for
your leadership in Afghanistan and for
you have several at this point
best-selling books but what was your
childhood like where did you come from
yeah I was an army brat
which meant my father was a career
soldier and his father before him
so I was one of six kids and five boys
and a girl
all the boys became soldier
and my sister married a soldier so we
were an army family that moved around
and then my father's career spanned
Korea and Vietnam so I was focused on
that I graduated from high school in
Northern Virginia and then went to West
Point when I was 17 years old in 1972 in
an era when that military was not very
popular so I was entering a profession
that that I was very interested in but
the nation had a different view of I
graduated from there in 76 while I was
there I'd met a young girl that I fell
in love with she was the daughter of a
career soldier her three brothers are
soldiers her sisters the widow of a
soldier so I grew up in a very army
environment I never thought about doing
anything but going in the army because
my father was my hero so when I
graduated in 76 I was sort of on a path
that may have been set for me almost did
birth so what do you think are sort of
the values that distinguish military
military families from from other
families because there is this pretty
stark divide now between people who
served in the military or even know
people who served in the military and
the rest of the civilian population such
a small percentage of our population now
serves in the military or even knows
someone who has served in the military
well they of course was an Arab back in
World War two 16 million people in
uniform and my father really came of age
in that era but starting right after the
Vietnam War they implemented the
volunteer army and so what happened is
you started having much more
professional military and most of my
career was spent in that environment
a few draftees were around but the
reality was the values that we grew up
with around my parents were the idea of
service the idea that you were going to
serve the nation and they didn't wear it
on their sleeves every day we didn't go
we weren't preached to to go serve the
nation but as sort of quietly the
expectation would be when you reached an
age you would do something that would
have value to the nation and I think
that's why my brothers all just sort of
reflexively went into the military my
father was a very quiet man he was a
Combat Infantryman had four silver stars
between Korea and Vietnam but if you
ever saw the movie the Great Santini
where the guy was bragging to my
father was the other end of that
spectrum so I thought a leadership and I
thought of service as quiet and humble
but yet focused and dedicated my father
was not an easy man but he was a very
thoughtful person and so I started to
equate that's what leaders do I want to
talk to you about leadership in just a
second but I have a couple more
questions about sort of the military
background one of the Robert Putnam was
a sociologist from Harvard he talks
about the idea that the military
instills this feeling of social fabric
and he talked about some of those values
that that are instilled through the
military do you think that those have
been lost more generally in civilian
society these values of service and and
trying to help out your neighbor yeah I
think they have if you look at what the
military does it's called soldier
ization the day you joined the military
they cut your hair differently they give
you different clothes they actually
change your name they call you a rank
and a name and they try to get you to be
part of a team and they try to get you
to identify with that team they want
individual performance but it's really
about the community that you're a part
of no man left behind any number of
sayings I think our society used to have
much more that fabric if you think of
frontier days where we did wagon trains
or barn raising or common defense or
volunteer fire departments were
necessary there was an absolute
practical requirement that you be
interacting and dependent upon your
neighbors and those neighbors might be
your religion they might be your
background but often they weren't but
they had to be a community we're in a
slightly different time now with those
communities of fragmented so now people
tend to know people that have the same
religion or occupation or income level
or education background and we have a
tendency to talk to them live with them
interact with them and because of social
media we can also choose who we interact
with virtually so we don't have to talk
to our physical neighbor we can sit on a
subway car ignore everybody else on the
subway car and feel as though we're
connecting to someone whoever they are
and that's who we choose so I think
what's happened is we have much less I
did
with the group we have much less feeling
that we are dependent upon them or
responsible for them and I think that's
that's very dangerous for society and
one of the things that I see rising from
that is this need almost a gut-level
need for the great leader you see this
in across Europe you're not seeing it in
the United States in a variety of ways
people who basically feel like since
we've lost the social fabric we need
some person who we can rally around and
this person will bring us all together
but in your book leaders you talk about
the idea that people have just this
grand mr. ception what leaders are and
what they actually do so what is your
definition of a leader yeah my
definition of a leader has evolved
tremendously through my life I was
absolutely a believer that there were
great men and women leaders and I spent
much of my life trying to be one of
those and trying to find those to
emulate and to follow over the years my
thinking has evolved where I actually
think leadership is this product of the
interaction between leaders and
followers and other contextual factors
and so as a consequence leadership is
almost a chemical reaction that occurs
so leaders enable that and leaders
protect that and leaders have a much
less active or controlling role than we
sometimes want to thank so as a
consequence what I want and expect from
leaders is much less the man or woman on
horseback who rides into the center and
says go this way and we will have lower
taxes and we'll have victory and
whatever it is we want because I know
they can't produce that I know that the
best they can do is produce something
between the followers and in the society
that enables us to do it that's
ultimately that who has to do things
that the larger group and so I start to
think of leadership as being those
people who can connect other people
those people who can make it not only
accepted but expected to be part of
something to commit to themselves to
serve a greater good in the book you
talk about three main myths of
leadership I was wondering if you might
explain what those are because one of
the things that's interesting about this
book is that it's a book about leaders
but it basically is shattering a lot of
illusions
folks have about our vision of a leader
as you were just talking about so what
are those three main myths they sure
shattered a lot of my illusions I grew
up with the idea of mythology and myths
really explain something we can't
otherwise explain and I explained to
people how I had this book with a
picture of Atlas standing holding up the
sky and you laugh at it got in a
g-string holding the sky up and then you
realize for a long time people accepted
that because they didn't have another
explanation of why this guy didn't
follow him and so having a guy that
they're doing it good as any and we
started to think that heroes would do
those things but as we really study
history we start to find that's never
been the case and so the three myths
that we came out with the first was a
formulaic myth and you and I are
absolute products of that when we go
through training in school we're taught
that if we do the seven Habits of Highly
Effective leaders or we do these things
or George Washington lists of traits or
behaviors we're going to be a good
leader and yet if you look historically
the data you find that people who
exhibit almost all of those often fail
and people who exhibit none of them
succeed and you're gonna wait a minute
so there's a disconnect the second is
the attribution myth and that's the idea
that everything an organization does or
fails to do is really dependent upon
that leader success or failure it was
interesting I got out of the military in
2010 and wrote my memoirs and I thought
that would be easy because I was there I
would know what happened but the reality
was we did all these interviews to
understand more fully complex events
that been a part of what we found is my
memory was good but it was stunningly
incomplete so I would make a decision
and there'd be this outcome and I'd get
credit for it as a big hero and in
reality when we did all the interviews
we found there's all this backstory of
all the people doing all the things that
really made it happen or stopped it from
happening so as a consequence
attributing success or failure to me was
really a myth it just wasn't accurate
and yet you think about how we read
history particularly through biographies
there's this spot
light on the leader and we followed them
through their lives and everything else
is sort of in the shadows so as a
consequence we tend to think everything
that happens is is where the light is
brightest the final myth is one that
really surprised me and that's the
result Smith because I think of myself
it's a hard-nosed analytical person
although I know I'm not I think that I
demand leaders who produce results
CEOs must make money politicians worst
men elections generals must win wars but
if you look historically that's not who
we follow we follow serial losers and
failures we don't follow people who
often more successful because really the
leadership that people want is far more
emotional than it is objective or
transactional and so as a consequence we
have these myths that we use to select
the leaders to elect them to follow them
and support them and they absolutely
lead us often to the wrong leaders one
of the things that's really interesting
is you start the book by talking about
how you took down a portrait of robert e
lee from your office and it was it was
fascinating for a variety of reasons
including the fact that we're now in the
midst of giant controversy about what to
do with statues of folks like robert e
lee i wondered if you might explain why
exactly you decided to do that and what
made you think okay well all of his
leadership qualities aside i still can't
have this person's portrait in my office
yeah absolutely first at the full story
I grew up near Washington or near robert
e lee's boyhood home i live about 70
feet from it now I went to Washington
Lee High School at West Point I lived in
Lee barracks I then served more than 30
years as an army officer as did Robert
Ely so not only did I grow up in his
shadow I followed his footsteps to my
life and and I tried to emulate him
because he was the epitome of a
gentleman of a courageous effective
brilliant leader and so when I was a
lieutenant my wife and I had zero money
my wife was an army brat too she bought
me a painting of robert e lee and his
confederate general officer uniform and
it wasn't really even a painting it was
a a print with clear acrylic painted
over it
25 bucks framed but in those days that
was a big chunk out of our monthly
budget and I hung it in our quarters for
the next 40 years wherever we lived and
I did it because I wanted it to remind
me of what I believed in and who I
believed in but I also when people came
to my house I was proud to have them go
Wow
look there's a picture of a truly
admirable person and that's who Stan
McChrystal identifies with I knew I
could never be robert e lee he was too
perfect
but he was sort of a beacon you could
move towards well after Charlottesville
in 2017 I remember my wife and it came
to me and she says I think you need to
get rid of the picture and I immediately
pushed back I said and you gave it to me
I couldn't never do that she says now
hey I I don't think you should have it
in the house I think it's communicating
something you don't believe in and I
said no he's just a soldier he's
non-political he's been dead 150 years
and she said that's what you think but
people in our house may think that you
are trying to signal that you believe in
white supremacy and things she knows I'm
close to and we went about a month with
this conversations last argument slash
wrestling match and after about a month
I came to the conclusion she was right
and on a Sunday morning I took down the
picture took it to the garage or a trash
can s and threw it away and it was not
an unemotional event and it's also the
time we started writing the book leaders
and we decided we would write a chapter
on robert e lee so i really studied him
in a way I never had before I'd studied
his campaigns and its history but I
studied him as a man who in 1861 after
32 years in the military after swearing
an oath to the United States of America
the exact same place I had done it many
years later he then turned on his nation
and he decides to join the Confederacy
and spends the next four years trying to
destroy the United States for the
maintenance of slavery the greatest evil
in American history and he did it not
without much reflection I mean people
think he just automatically wouldn't
that was not true he went through quite
a Plutarch Ian moment studying and
contemplating but ultimately he made the
decision to go first with Virginia to
the south and I think he got it wrong I
think it's the opposite decision that
his role model George Washington would
have done and it's interesting because
when I look at that I think he got it
completely wrong but I don't think
Robert Ely is completely evil there's
still much about Robert ela I admire
there's still many of the things about
him that I would like to emulate but now
instead of him being a two-dimensional
painting or a big statue that is just
perfection personified and I see him as
a human being I seem as a flawed man he
did a lot of things well and he did
something spectacularly wrong that makes
him human that makes him like you or I
fraud and so I can think about him now
not as an icon but as a man and I think
that that's who I can learn from well I
want to talk to you more about that in
just a second because I I do fear that
we may be living in an era where
political correctness uses the fact that
these guys were men to erase them from
history altogether and I want to talk to
you about that but first let's talk
about your investment so maybe you're
just learning how to invest maybe you're
interested in learning how to invest
well you should try Robin Hood it's an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options crypto currencies
all commission-free
they strive to make financial services
work for everyone not just for wealthy
folks it's a non intimidating way for
stock market newcomers to invest for the
first time with true confidence it's
simple and intuitive it's got a clear
design with data presented in a really
easy to do just way other brokerages can
charge up to ten bucks for every trade
you know wipe out your internet profit
margin but Robin Hood doesn't charge
commission fees they trade stocks and
you keep all your profits it's got
easy-to-understand charts market data
you can place a trade in just four taps
on your smartphone and the Robin Hood
web platform also lets you view stock
collections curate for you like 100 most
popular or social media or curated
categories like female CEOs and analysts
ratings of buy hold sell for every
single stock learn how to invest as you
build your portfolio get educated in how
exactly to trade in the stock market
discover new stocks track for favorite
companies with personalized news feeds
custom notifications from
nice movement so you never missed the
right moment to invest and right now
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
build your portfolio go check them out
at ben shapiro dot Robin Hood com
that's Ben Shapiro dot Robin Hood
dot-com go check them out right now so
stand back to the issue of how we should
view our heroes so this sort of begs the
question as to whether there should be
statues or portraits at all because the
truth is that every single hero that we
have is a flawed human being because
we're all flawed human being so we're
now seeing people try to recapitulate
Winston Churchill and try to paint
Winston Churchill as a racist we're
seeing people who a lot of the same
folks who wanted to take down the robert
e lee's statue in Charlottesville also
wanted to remove the Thomas Jefferson
statue from Charlottesville
even though Thomas Jefferson of course
was one of the creators of University of
Virginia so where do we draw the line
between recognizing that these were
human beings flawed human beings with
good qualities that we want to emulate
and completely wiping them away or
should we have statutes should we have
portraits yeah everyone has to make a
personal journey and decision on this I
think we should I think we need heroes I
think we need statues I think we need
paintings I think we need to name things
after people because if we don't honor
people who do a lot I think future
generations won't have the same
commitment they won't understand how
important that is if you look at
monuments on battlefields they never
have a thing that says we won we kick
their butt what they symbolize is people
who when they were needed served and
that's what our leaders do I think we
also need to understand that every one
of our leaders is human George
Washington owned slaves everyone in
their life has made bad decisions I've
made a bunch of them and I can't back
away from them I have to own them but
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't have
those things that represent the best and
what they did there are times when you
could look at a statue of Robert Ely and
you could say there's so much good in
robert e lee that we should admire that
we should try to to follow it doesn't
mean we try to do everything they do
Thomas Jefferson he did so much for the
nation it doesn't mean we should owed
slaves and so we've got to be mature
enough to do the
things holistically and have the
conversation if somebody says ben
shapiro is an amazing leader and we're
gonna put a statue up we've got to be
honest enough to say he was amazing
human being which means by definition
not everything was perfect and and we've
got to live with that and that's the
problem with the mythology because we
want to put them on a pedestal and we
want to burnish them till they're
perfect and then we don't want to hear
anything negative about our heroes and
that's not fair and it's really not
healthy well in the American system one
of the areas where leaders really do
have a very large personal impact is in
the area foreign policy where of course
you were extraordinarily active as has
the leading commander in in Afghanistan
when you look at the situation in
Afghanistan right now do you think that
there is hope for the future of
Afghanistan do you think that we should
be pulling out do you think we should be
ramping up the number of troops we have
there because it seems like every
president for the past couple of term
the past couple administrations at least
has basically said let's get out and
then inserted more troops and then
inserted more troops and it just seems
like a muddle do you see any outcome
there yeah I think next question get
asked me how to improve education in
America equally simple task
I do think Afghanistan's got a future I
think by definition there will be in
Afghanistan after you and I are both
long dead and buried I think the best we
can do in Afghanistan is try to move it
in as helpful a direction as we can I
don't think we as the United States and
right now even inside Afghanistan can
fix Afghanistan what I think is going to
happen is there's been this 30 plus
years of chaos the Afghanistan that
exists today was torn inside out upside
down from 1973 on civil war the war with
the Soviets and whatnot society doesn't
look like traditional pre 1973
Afghanistan did so it's going to take a
generation or two or three to really fix
it I would say that the first thing we
do is need to be very realistic about
that we need to say we should partner
with Afghanistan we should help
Afghanistan we should be strategic
allies I would leave troops in there now
some
I wouldn't leave thousands and thousands
I wouldn't send a lot more because I'm
humble about the effect we could have if
we did that I don't think that we'd have
the the output we want at the same times
I think just turning our back touching
the stove and say it's hot and turn in
the back it's what we did in 1989 when
we pulled out suddenly after the Soviets
departed and Afghanistan needed
strategic partners and and no one was
there this will be a little like raising
a child I mean couples every once while
they say we're having a baby I said no
you're not you having a person and that
person's gonna be around a long time and
you'll likely be involved in that so I
think we need to be very mature about
what we can and cannot do in Afghanistan
don't raise our or their expectations
beyond what is probably achievable be
honest with the American people in the
world of what we're trying to do and
what we think we can and also be open
for opportunities there's a lot of
twists in terms of history when suddenly
positive opportunities open up
negotiations with the Taliban peace that
sort of thing and if we're postured as
partners I think we can help them take
advantage of it now do you think honesty
is a political winner in this area
because it seems like the only
politicians who win on this particular
score are the ones who don't tell the
truth about the situation in Afghanistan
and what it's going to require from the
United States because we're constantly
telling folks maybe we still live in the
aftermath of a world war 2 mentality
that will win a war we'll come home
that'll be the end of it and then if a
politician like John McCain says well
you know in order to actually secure
this area we may have to be there for
decades and decades and decades then
people say no we're not interested in
that at all and then of course the
person who was elected who pledged never
to do that immediately does exactly what
John McCain said that he would do and
just leaves people there for decades and
decades and decades I mean can the
American people stand any honesty on
these these scores do you think well
whether they can stand it or not I think
the American people need to get it and I
actually think they want it if we go all
the way back to World War two and other
times where we said we'll win World War
two have come out and then we spend
decades there we told people in Vietnam
things about that war that were not true
and the whole point of the Pentagon
Papers was to show that in many cases
the United States government
you a reality on the ground that they
would not communicate for political
purposes to the American people and I
understand the expedience and the
temptation to do that I believe we have
to have a basic honesty with the
American people the problem is it's not
an applause line it doesn't do well in
an election where you stand up and say
I'm gonna cut your taxes pull it off
game and say I'm gonna do all these
things and it'll be great sometimes you
have to look at them and say we're gonna
have to pay more we're gonna have to do
more and it's gonna take 30 years and
you're unlikely to get that thunderous
response but we owe the American people
that honesty the American people
themselves are their sons or daughters
or at a minimum their treasure or the
people going places and they have a
right to know that this is if it's going
to be hard tell them if we don't know
tell them not to we think we need to do
something we're not sure how this will
play out but we frankly don't have a
better option than trying this and
that's that's where we'll go
I actually think over time the American
people not only want that but they would
respond well to it when you are the top
commander in Afghanistan you famously
had some pretty public quarrels with
etham presidents of the United States
Barack Obama
in retrospect how do you evaluate
President Obama's performance on
Afghanistan and do you think that it was
a mistake for example you'd recommended
that more troops be put in a particular
point he ended up going with sort of a
halfway measure with fewer troops how do
you evaluate those decisions yeah I'm
probably not that the most unbiased
person that to give I was sent to
Afghanistan I'd been there for a number
of years before and then I was back on
the Joint Staff and I was sent in the
summer of 2009 and the situation
Afghanistan was markedly worse than I
think anybody thought it was and it had
been getting worse when everybody said
we got to get out of Iraq but
Afghanistan's the necessary war and
that's what President Obama had in his
campaign and then I think when he get
into office it was a bit of a shock to
he and the people with him that in fact
it was worse than it was going to take
more commitment they were schooled in
the history of Vietnam and I don't blame
him that and from the day that they
entered office I think there was great
frustration and as in
our administration that suddenly the
military and Defense Department was
saying we need to double down in
Afghanistan we need to put more troops
and greater commitment and this is
almost a replay of what they believed
that they had read about Vietnam and
they were absolutely parallels so you
start with this growing discomfort
distrust between that the Department of
Defense and this new administration
nobody evil I was in the Pentagon during
the first part of that it's good people
on both sides but you could see it
growing then when I've gotten
Afghanistan and I was asked to do an
assessment and I came back and said we
have to change the strategy and I didn't
know when I went over there that I was
gonna have to ask for more troops but
after we did all these computer
simulations and everything I realized we
need more troops that was not going to
be popularly received back in DC and it
wasn't
I actually commend President Obama for
putting everyone through a pretty
rigorous decision-making process to come
to the conclusion to accept the
recommendation for more forces he didn't
provide all that that were asked but he
did it that was a tough political
decision if we if we were collectively
wrong then and I think we were when he
made the decision I could almost hear in
his voice when he gave his speech at
West Point buyer's remorse he was doing
it but he didn't like it there was a
group of people said the generals that
pushed him into it and from my
standpoint we weren't pushing him wasn't
our war you know we're there trying to
answer the question if you want the
outcome that you've asked for this is
what it takes but you could almost sense
that we're doing it but we hate it and
whenever you're in that situation it's
like going to your in-laws for dinner
when you don't want to go and you're in
the car driving over and people are
unhappy we needed to sort that out
because that's a recipe for a bad
outcome we really needed to stop get all
the players and step back and say if we
are not more united and not more
comfortable with this decision as we go
forth to execute it I think we're going
to have problems
I could have spoken up more I think
other players could have and I think
it's a cautionary tale for future
endeavors for the United States and
foreign policy because certain things
are going to be hard and take a long
time and if you don't start with a
certain unity if you don't start with a
level of resolve
you almost preordained problems so you
think it was a problem that he was
giving withdrawal timetables from the
very outset I I would not have
recommended that in fact I recommended
against that I understood the political
reason for it but I think in retrospect
as we all look at it that made it more
difficult and what do you think you know
now bring us up to present of how the
Trump administration is handled
Afghanistan it's almost become the
Forgotten war it's on the headlines
anymore we don't we don't read about it
very often the president again seems to
be of divided mind about whether we
ought to be there or whether we ought
not to be there what have you made of
the Trump administration's handling of
this or the Defense Department under a
general mattis well I know there are
good people good people I know out there
working really hard trying to get a good
outcome I don't think the policy is
clear
I don't think America's objectives are
clear if they are clear they're not
clear to me they're not cleared a lot of
people in the American public and I
think when you have sons daughters and
husbands and wives over risk in their
lives they need to be clear now I would
be the first to tell you maybe the
leadership has to stand up and say this
is extraordinary complex there is no
simple solution at hand the best we know
to do now is to continue on the current
course of action and hope that things
evolve again that's not an applause line
that's not going to sound great to
people but when you look at the
alternatives to pulling out and
potentially of an al Qaeda safe haven or
dumping a bunch more troops and
increasing the the level of violence
sometimes you say well you know
maintenance may be a rational course of
action but we need to explain that to
people we can't act like it doesn't
exist it's not fair we need to put it on
the table and say if someone else has a
better more clever plan please send it
in let's get back to sort of what the
central tenets of foreign policy should
be so it seems like the the shift in
direction of the American mind has
an isolationist in orientation really
since the second Bush administration
that after the war in Iraq started to go
badly in 2004-2005 and we required the
surge that the American people turned
against the the war in Iraq they turned
against the war in Afghanistan to a
certain extent they've turned against in
in many ways the idea that America ought
to be a forceful presence on the world
stage and then of course as you say
presidents get empowered they look at
the actual situation on the table they
say well we don't really have much
choice about this so we have to continue
doing what we're doing what do you think
the central planks of American foreign
policy you ought to be well what's
America's interest in the world and how
forceful ought we to be in in pushing it
yeah our interest in the world are huge
think of the times when we've really
gotten it wrong we failed it join the
League of Nations almost a hundred years
ago and we paid a big price for that the
reality is the world is there and it's
not going anywhere in fact it is more
relevant to us on a daily basis because
things are physically closer now because
of transportation and the speed of
digits economically they are now
intertwined and we can't disconnect
those we don't want to disconnect them
in fact our level of prosperity in the
United States is dependent upon a robust
global trading and interaction as is the
rest of the world our peace and security
are best secured furthest from our
shores
they are best secured by conditions in
other countries that make people not
want to emigrate or not want to be
terrorists or whatever so I'm very much
of the mindset that we need to think
globally now do I care more about the
United States and other countries we all
do but that doesn't mean that we put our
head in the sand and we get inside walls
and we wait and see what happens
it means we interact I actually believe
that we need a robust network of
alliances around the world with people
who trust us and admire our values I
believe that we need in a robust network
of commercial connections so that would
be trade agreements and whatnot I think
we should be active in that we should be
out with American values constantly not
saying American values are perfect and
therefore you must adopt them
but saying American values are something
we believe in here they are see them
don't don't wonder about them from afar
share them if you want and if you will
and I think that we need to be prepared
to to make the kinds of decisions to
support allies when necessary also to to
oppose people or impose nations around
the world when when they upset the
status quo and it's easy for us to say
or it's tempting to say well we're tired
to be in the world's policeman why can't
other people spend as much on defense as
we do or do as much or lose as many
soldiers in combat as we do I got that
but I would respond we get so many
advantages from being that nation in the
world we are economically politically
socially advantaged for the fact that we
are engaged in the world and we've had
this superpower position and I think
that everyone needs to understand that
for all the things the price we've paid
for that we've gotten many times the
return in the value to us and I think
young Americans particularly need to be
educated that the world is there and
that we're not superior they need to go
learn foreign languages they need to go
learn foreign cultures they need to
interact not so that they can become
them but so they understand them that so
they empathize them I think the thing
that hurts us most is when we look afar
at some culture and we think will they
wear rags on their heads or they don't
speak English so they must be messed up
or they they believe a different kind of
religion and then you get up close you
realize they're rational people and they
do some things that are pretty
thoughtful and in some cases more
thoughtful than we do and it doesn't
mean we have to change but means we have
to understand enough to empathize so
you've served under a bunch of President
and obviously observed presidents while
you weren't serving which president do
you think has best emulated the sort of
perform policy that you find attractive
or worthwhile yeah I think in some bits
many of them have you go back to my very
youth I'm in the excitement of John F
Kennedy very much star
the Peace Corps he said that the Peace
Corps wouldn't really do what we wanted
by getting young Americans out in
tonight a hundred thousand young
Americans doing those things overseas
President Nixon reaching out to China
for all the faults that President Nixon
had he actually was very globally
oriented he understood that America was
going to prosper based upon how the
chessboard of the world worked and he
worked very hard at it
President Reagan of course reached out
to to Europe and he gave a little shove
on the Berlin Wall at the right time and
he did it in a way that allowed American
values to come across not as jingoistic
but very very positive and a lot of
people wanted to emulate not just Braun
Reagan but America in that period we do
a lot of things wrong in the world but I
think the idea and and while nobody gets
it right
the much-maligned President Obama speech
in 2009 when he reached out to the Arab
world and he basically said some of the
things we've been doing over the last
eight years have not been fair to you if
you strip aside the idea nobody ever
likes Ted to be apologizing for our own
country that's not a bad thing to be
willing to look out to the world and say
we don't always get it right what we're
willing to do is come halfway what we're
willing to do is to try to partner with
you
and so that give and take it it's got to
be organic it's not it's presidential
leadership and it's most mature well
it's really interesting too first of all
I have to acknowledge that I was a
massive critic of the 2009 speech
because I thought he went far too much
in one direction as opposed to the other
I don't think that he drew the balance
properly particularly when he was
talking with many nations that have had
a long record of supporting terrorism
but with that said it's interesting that
most of the presidents that you cite is
being you know the sort of foreign
policy leaders they like existed during
the Cold War era do you think that the
once the Cold War consensus is shattered
and it's that that has sort of shattered
our notion of what foreign policy you
ought to be more generally in its
fractured Republicans its fractured
Democrats it used to be the at least the
the
deal was that foreign-policy stopped
when knew that that argument stopped
once he hit the water's edge but that
hasn't been the case for most of my
lifetime certainly I wonder if you see
that hard gap as happening when the
Soviet Union fell yeah that's
interesting because it took some
structure and logic away from our
foreign policy because regardless of
whether you're Republican Democrat or
whatever when the Cold War existed you
politically and just logically sort of
fell in in line with certain things we
had to do I think that there's much to
come around now but we haven't found how
to do that we are backing into another
Cold War I fear and Russia of course
doesn't have near the power that the
Soviet Union did but they've got some
serious intent and it wouldn't take much
for Europe to be in a pretty difficult
place again China is not a backward
nation anymore so I think the idea that
we need to be serious about American
foreign policy it's not a ping-pong ball
we can bounce around internally and and
ignore how the rest of the world sees it
I think that we really need an approach
in America that says when you leave the
shores of the United States we may not
agree on everything but we are going to
be much more tightly aligned one of the
things that always shocks people when
you travel like I spent so many years
away we don't know what's happening
inside country X to any great degree
most people around the world even in
small countries know an incredible
amount about what happens inside the
United States
our political eliminations the comments
and whatnot so everything we are doing
is done on a world stage that I'm not
sure we always appreciate so how would
you handle the Russia situation you talk
about the possibility of backing into a
Cold War obviously the Obama
administration seated an awful lot of
territory not just in Crimea but but
actual kind of psychological territory
to the Russians in places like Syria the
Trump administration obviously has its
own problems with its dealings with
Russia they may be more practically anti
Russia in a lot of their dealings giving
the Ukrainians deadly weaponry for
example but obviously the president has
spoken in very warm terms of Vladimir
Putin Putin is a bad actor on the world
stage without a doubt what do you think
is the best way for the United States
to confront the Russians is it to be
more aggressive in our language and be
more clear with the consequences that
will follow if they were to violate
certain certain lines yeah Ben that's
that's an essential question I don't
think that we need to be aggressive in
our actions to the point of provoking
but I think we need to be more firm I
think if you go back to the Cold War
there need to be certain expectations
almost like the article 5 or if you do
this that that's an absolute cost in the
redline I think President Putin has
taken advantage of a certain amount of
uncertainty his invasion of Georgia the
move back into the Mideast
we weren't very clear with us happening
in Syria and there back if I was the
Baltic States now I feel much less
comfortable than I'd like to
and of course Ukraine speaks for itself
so I think we need to be more firm with
Russia I think we need to understand
President Putin he came of age during
Chechnya and he was very aggressive and
every time he's been aggressive since
his popularity
popularity is buttressed and of course
he's become an oligarch himself so I
think we need to call that for what it
is at the same time I don't think we
need to take Russia and say they're part
of the evil access and and the world
won't be safe until Russia is
obliterated cuz that's not true Russia
will evolve like every other country but
for it nice the next foreseeable future
we need to treat Russia for what it is
it's an opponent it is a rogue state it
is as far as we can see not to be
trusted in in many many things and so
that means we've got to stand united
against it and what do you make of China
because this has always been the
conundrum is that they're a huge trading
partner with us obviously we tend to
think that opening China was a good
thing for purposes at least of
separating them off from the Soviet
Union at the time but it also enabled
them to become a much more long-lasting
power perhaps if we don't open China
they collapsed the same way the Soviet
Union does economically in any case
we're now in a trade standoff with China
China has obviously gotten very
aggressive in the South China Sea how
should we be treating Chinese Chinese
ambitions yeah as
an inevitable competitor and when I say
competitor I don't use the same turn I
think the Soviets are actually an
opponent and an enemy right now I think
China is a competitor I think if we
hadn't opened China it would at some
point open itself and just the energy of
the people and whatnot
they've just been remarkably effective
at doing that because they matched this
commercial economy with a very unified
government so they've been able to move
things it's not without flaws but the
reality is now they offer extraordinary
ability to come compete with us and not
just in ways that are obvious and
building aircraft carriers and going in
the South China Sea those matter but in
reality is they put their tentacles out
around the world in Africa the invest
they take Natural Resources that's where
we are losing in sort of the mid term as
we think of America first they think
China first but they think but China
first over there and I think that's
important the last part we need to look
at is there is the equivalent of a heavy
trade competition we have to protect our
interests on intellectual property we
have got to be pushing for fair trade
and I think we can do that I could think
we can do that without war but we need
to be disciplined enough to do that
people will criticize President Trump or
poke in China about trade but in reality
we've had a lot of firms and people in
the US you've benefited in the short
term from things that hurt us in the
long term in terms of buying things from
China and whatnot I think we need to get
to a middle on that we need to say it's
not sustainable unless we trade like
trading partners and not like one person
doesn't follow rules and the other does
now what should we do better on
obviously the three main kind of foreign
policy issues we've discussed two of
them Russia and China Iran is the other
one it has significant regional ambition
it's pushed into every place from Iraq
to Yemen and it's it's created basically
a bifurcated Middle East where this by
almost accident this this sort of
newfangled counter alliance between
Israel and Jordan in Egypt and Saudi
Arabia has formed well what do you think
is the best way for the United States to
deal with Iran yeah I think one way is
to cover our
and pretend it's not there and then take
our hands away and if it's still there
we'd better come up with the other plan
is 18 and I'm a ninety million Iranians
it's Persia
it's the Persian Empire it had a period
when we thought that they were the
bulwark of democracy under shall raise a
Pilate and from 53 when we helped him
get into power until he left in the late
70s it was sort of this thing that was
going to be really good for the Mideast
because they bought stuff from us and
they did what we wanted them of course
with Ayatollah Khomeini in this really
difficult period where if you really
look at history we were as bad to the
Iranians during that period as they were
to us and so if you're an Iranian you
have every reason to look at the United
States and say wow you know you guys are
just everything you can do to hurt us
you have done you you helped Iraq after
a rock invaded or on you shot down the
Iranian airline or 1988 killing us 300
people 60 some kids we've just done a
lot of things and then in 2003 to their
surprise they are named to the axis of
evil by George W Bush and suddenly they
they're in the winner's circle and the
axis of evil going how did that happen
now they have done an enormous number of
things I have fought Iranians in Iraq
and whatnot and didn't appreciate that
at all they are involved with Hamas
Lebanese Hezbollah sort of you name it
in the region and now in Syria so
heavily they're a difficult regional
actor and they need to clean up that act
at the same time they're a reality and
so just like Arab countries got together
and said we don't admit the existence of
Israel and we're just gonna wait to the
chance to wipe them off the face of the
earth around being one of them if any of
these other coalition's say we're just
gonna wait until we can wipe a run off
the face of the earth and they go away
that's that's equally unrealistic the
Iranian people are not all aligned
behind the supreme leader by any means
but they are all aligned behind Iran and
so the idea that Iran will be a powerful
regional
player is rational it's popular inside
around and it's inevitable see the
possibility of a coup inside Iran I do I
mean I think that that kind of thing
could happen over time but if there was
a coup inside Iran the next leader if
they were if they were what I predict
would be a strong person who would want
a strong regional power wouldn't love
Saudi Arabia you know so it wouldn't
change the dynamics as much as we think
it would it might be much easier to
negotiate with and stop some of the
rogue behavior but the reality is they
have national interests and those
national interests are we disagree with
some of them but they have been
rationally pursued and so I think if if
we we have to look at the region that
way I want to ask about the the major
controversy that's broken out over
recent years has been the sort of social
engineering of the military and in the
past we've seen that for great use with
regard to the integration of the
military under Harry Truman for example
but there's been a lot of complaint from
folks who are on the front lines I've
talked to many of them who are upset
with the idea of women in combat roles
for example on the front lines or the
new push for transgender members of the
military where do you come down on how
the military should be used for social
engineering should it be used are these
things should we just be worried about
what makes the military stronger
how do you think all that math works out
yeah I believe that the military has to
reflect society I was a cadet at West
Point from 72 to 76 and during the last
two years they made the decision to let
women attend West Point now the first
woman didn't show up until right after I
graduated with a new class and I
remember old grad said that literally
West Point would cease to exist it would
slide into the Hudson River and float
away and all this kind of thing and of
course that has not been the outcome the
women have come and they've done pretty
darn well every time something in my
career the integration happened before
me but it was still sort of maneuvering
along women at West Point then women in
combat there was this great angst over
it but the truth is women were in combat
about ten years before we had the final
decision in Iraq and Afghanistan they
just were they were shooting
they were doing all the things you have
to do and in my experience they were
doing just fine the same with gage the
military we we had that the pretty
painful era when anyone who was
identified as homosexual was immediately
chapter Dalit he was chapter 15 they
called it then we had Don't Ask Don't
Tell which was it encouraged people to
be deceptive to lie
now but it maybe was a necessary bridge
to something later the reality is we had
gays serving in the military doing just
fine and most of the force didn't care
either if you were a good soldier sailor
Airman marine some bits of fun whatever
you do is fine
I think transgender is exactly the same
way I think transgender you know it's
that sort of the latest thing that a few
people will get upset about at the end
of the day the middle and terror is
necessarily a meritocracy because you
need the people who operate with you to
be effective therefore you just want
people who will perform well and if
somebody wants to volunteer military
wants to perform they'll do well now we
need to sometimes help mandate that
military leaders have got to help the
force you know because there's always
different opinions inside the force got
to help them along and the military can
be a great exemplar for the rest of
society look you know it works just fine
what are you worried about everybody
needs to have equal rights and when I
talk about that you think about the
African Americans that so desperately
wanted to fight in the Civil War and you
think why in god's name when you want to
fight if the white man will do it for
you let him do the fighting and die and
we'll get freed they understood
implicitly that if they fought if they
on an equal footing accepted the cost
and risk of that that they would be more
legitimate as citizens they would have a
larger ability to argue for the kinds of
rights that they deserved in America I
think that's true of military service
today for every part of society so in
making all of that happen the two issues
that I've
I've talked with with various members of
military are the issues of troop
cohesion and standards themselves
meaning the worry about the lowering of
particular physical standards for
example to absorb more women into if you
want a female Navy SEAL women on average
don't tend to perform the same way that
men do physically do we try to lower
those standards and if we do how does
that make our military stronger and when
it comes to transgenderism for example
you have a biological male who now who
now believe this woman and should be
bericht with a bunch of women and those
women are uncomfortable with it how do
we deal with those issues are the women
wrong is that is that should we be you
know scolding the women for being non
tolerant or how should we dealing with
those yeah it's great on the first one
on standards this is harder than it
sounds I believe you said standards for
different military occupational
specialties an infantryman carries a lot
of equipment and a squad of non
infantryman have some common equipment
they all have to help carry so if a
person doesn't have the physical ability
capability to do that it's not fair to
the rest of the squad so I think we have
to be really good about coming up with
standards and it will make it uneven
because there are physical differences
now the thing about it is we got to make
sure we're fair because there's
sometimes a tendency to say okay we're
gonna make these standards and you you
gerrymander them so that anyone who's a
female you know we got to be better than
that and I think I do see that on the
other part this is a sociological thing
and and I'm not quite sure how to deal
with that because you can't argue that
if somebody is transgender and then
they're put in with the other group that
people will feel uncomfortable I think
we're gonna have to feel our way along
here because I know that if you've
gotten me 40 years ago and you said I
was going to be in a squad with you know
gay men I probably would have said
Eiling it's good idea because I'll be
vulnerable then you learned that's not
the way it works
I think the transgender part will just
sort of have to work it out I don't
think that we should automatically beat
everybody over the head and say you're
horrible because you want a man who's
now become a woman you don't want her to
live in the female
Barracks if i'm a female because you
have to respect them at the same time we
have got to understand that we can't let
people use things like that as reasons
to maintain old biases they used to say
that African Americans weren't smart
enough to be soldiers they used to say
they couldn't fight they said all kinds
of stuff and of course it's been proven
wrong time and time and again so we
gotta push
those natural biases but at the same
time understand that there are there are
things that people do worry about so
you've been talked about as a potential
2020 Democratic nominee are you a
Democrat politically I never was
anything I'd never thought of myself
very political I think that now I come
down that America needs a different way
ahead I think that America needs a
centrist way ahead I think that our two
political parties in my view have both
gone too far to respect to the ends of
the spectrum I'm not sure they represent
people like me as much as I'd like them
to I mean I have things I believe in on
different issues but the reality is once
you get out to the fringes I feel like
I'm in a foreign land
so can you name some of those like what
do you think that the the Republican
Party has gone too far to the right and
where do you think the Democratic Party
has gone too far to the left if you take
the Democrats I'm not a socialist I'm
great believer in you know people
workers I don't think socialism works
it's not human nature so people should
have to work for what they get there's
an awful high level of responsibility
required at the same time I believe that
government has a significant role in
society a significant role to give
people opportunity to help them do that
so just because if by accident of birth
I am born in West Virginia and in West
Virginia the coal industry for example
is struggling against all the other
competitors and and and that's not
surprising I don't think that I ought to
be left to fall behind people who happen
to be born in New York I think that the
federal government has
Rolle - look at that and says how do we
help the parts of our society that
needed for a hundred and fifty years we
depended upon coal from places like West
Virginia but hadn't been for people
willing to go a mile underground to dig
coal so we can make electricity and
power boats and things like that we
wouldn't have had the Industrial
Revolution then when energy shifts for
us to suddenly go I don't need you
anymore good luck with that you know
that's not fair I think we need to we
have a responsibility for each other and
insularly when when we get very far on
the right we get very conservative in
terms of not letting immigrants in or
things like that I don't think that
reflects America I think America is an
immigrant country I think it's a
compassionate country I think it's a
country that gives people opportunities
accepts responsibility for things like
that and so when you get out there
that's when I I start to to want us to
pull back to the middle so the fact that
you've been discussed as a Democratic
candidate would you be more likely to
run into Democrat primary or a
Republican primary if you were at some
point to run yeah I don't I'm really not
at the point to say that I do want to
say that I think we need the best people
we can find a run for office one of the
things that disturbs me most
particularly about young people is not
this that they're not dramatically
political they're not a lot of young
Republicans and young Democrats what I
find is a lot of young people are
apolitical they're almost non-political
they're almost anti political because of
what they seem and the people who run
for office not all but they're an awful
lot of very ambitious people running for
office that's actually not what I want I
really want young people to run for
office who are pretty centrist want the
society be better maybe they don't want
to stay a politician forever and that
actually would like that do they want to
do that for just a little while and it
doesn't matter to me whether they go a
bit to the left to the right you know I
endorsed a Republican this time and a
couple of Democrats because I was
looking for people I thought could
compliment
now do you think that there's a
possibility than anyone who's actually
serious about foreign policy can win in
the near future I mean what we've seen
is on the Democratic side of the aisle
there's been significant attempts
President Obama obviously did this to to
cut the military the the when Jim Webb
ran for president in 2016
basically the death of his campaign is
when he talked about his military
experience actually in a primary debate
and and on the right obviously President
Trump took an extraordinarily
isolationist tack in in the primaries
and ran roughshod over people who were
more interventionist or at least more in
my view realistic on foreign policy do
you think that we've reached sort of an
isolationist end point and is there
going to be a resurgence of folks who
want to take foreign policy seriously in
either party and if so which party do
you see taking it more seriously in the
near future then that's a really good
question and I think that your jet your
analysis is right you go back to the
Kennedy Nixon debates they were talking
about the missile gap and that the need
to do things and that is almost entirely
out of discussions now political because
it just doesn't resonate for domestic
elections to run on foreign policy
things most of them are frustrating and
so if you get out there you get tarred
with it I think we have to I think we're
gonna have to get back to that I think
we're going to be pulled to it my sense
is we may be pulled by events more than
I don't think a candidate suddenly going
to arise in the near future who says I'm
the foreign policy president because I
think people will go yeah but you know I
need a job or I need health care all the
things they do need I think the foreign
policy president arises when foreign
policy pulls us there and then we go wow
we really need competent leadership for
foreign policy I think a president who
gets in office whoever he is we need to
select them for the team they can build
around them much of domestic policy is
is competent government it's just
getting things done that need to get
done and then on the foreign policy side
I think you need to have a president
with enough experience enough maturity
and enough willingness because that's
where you really have to really
America a bit think of that the leaders
who have the presidents you've done
great things in foreign policy they tend
to be a step ahead of the American
people because the American people
necessarily are looking at daily
business so I have one final question
before I want to ask you about the
leadership tips that you give to young
Americans based on your book and your
experiences but before we get to general
McChrystal's answer you have to be a
daily wire subscriber to subscribe go to
daily wire comm click subscribe you can
hear the end of our conversation there
now general McChrystal thank you so much
for stopping I really is an honor to
have you here and it's really been a
pleasure taking up some of your time
thanks again for your service and
everything that you do really appreciate
it's been my honor thank you so much
[Music]
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan case hair
and makeup is by Jess wah alvera a Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production a
copyright for publishing 2019
you